something every actor should know while
playing as spy is um how to hold a
[Music]
gun hi I'm Maya oin and I'm Donald
Glover and this is how we became Mr and
Mrs Smith you want us to do a right or
no that's fun I like it that was
fun I feel like our gun trainers were
really good because they were you know
they've seen a lot of actors hold guns
in shows and they get really peeved by
certain tells yeah like there was a lot
of like you know I think all everybody
always wants to be like that he's like
they don't do that they they do that
like that thing where like you know he's
like why would you do that like it takes
too much time and you just also not like
wincing with one eye it's like you need
both eyes open that something I you just
want to go why would do that it looks
cool yeah like a lot of things that you
we think of that feel like yeah Jack
Reacher I was just trying to be Jack
Reacher the entire time entire time I I
I made her call me
Jack I likeed thinking of Sigourney
Weaver from Alien just the moments when
she was very Steely uh and uh that was a
big inspiration and then Jame Birkin was
just kind of the physical inspiration
and Fran was my inspiration sometimes oh
I didn't know that yeah here and there
that makes sense to believably create
chemistry I mean it was a lot of work a
lot of work on our own I had to journal
about Donald and do like dream analysis
dream therapy no I mean it was very easy
we I felt like he was you were one of my
friends from okay I know you don't think
I'm cool enough to be your friend I
don't know I just don't
know no I now I feel the same way I feel
like I've known Maya way longer than we
actually
it's very strange but it was it it
mirrored uh real life in that like we
the the order in which we shot
everything was you know the pilot and
then the second episode so it is a meet
cute so we were really getting to know
each other in the beginning and then I
feel like our chemistry got even
stronger and grew as we filmed cuz we
just got closer and we just knew each
other at that point
yeah this your first time in New York
should we be asking each other
that
have you ever killed
anyone no no no not really really no May
is really good at um I'm scared what are
you going to say why what do you think
what do you think I'm going to say I
don't know go say
it Maya's uh I feel like she's really
good at
like remembering things as far as uh and
Donald's not yeah I'm not I'm not really
really like I'm not good at remembering
because I'm just I I am kind you you
used the very gentle term which was like
Donald's very present yes and I was like
yeah I guess you know and I think that
allowed me to lay into that I mean the
character of John Alo because he's kind
of like that and he's he's like yeah
it's all Jazz you know mayy we we'll
improv it which I which I like to do but
you have to plan a lot more and I feel
like she is a planner and I think she
does think about those things forced me
to be PL she she knew what this was
before like she'll she'll be like oh we
have Rotten Tomatoes at like 125 like
I'll be like you you saw this you saw
the schedle I know well then and then we
would talk about this that Donald I I
think I've told you the story but our
nutritionist when we were training this
would talk to me and say like you know
if I tell Donald to eat a carrot he'll
just say okay and he'll eat a carrot and
then if I ask you to eat a carrot Maya
you ask can I sauté it can we put in it
and can I put a little cheese and she's
like you negotiate whereas Donald I feel
like is is and and your character which
did help me is like if you tell me to
jump I'm going to jump up cuz he's a
soldier he's a soldier right so it's
like it's like yeah this is what I have
and you you get what you get you don't
get upset and I think that just helped
open Jane up and it helped me uh it
helped me loosen up so I think it helps
get into the character you you're
sitting underneath a shelter I made I
made this fire
I food fire water I was saying this
before I think we improved a lot of the
there's a lot of improv improvisation
with the um arguments I think like
arguments wise like it's just hard to
argue like we would have the script and
a spine and then go off of it sometimes
because we would bring in our own you
know techniques of arguing MH yeah
exactly like I think everybody argues
different but it's also just hard to
argue off the script and we didn't have
to like we didn't have to hit it exactly
and we I remember there was one night
where we it was a big argument that we
kind we kind of re like we got rid of
together we all got together with and
we're like okay we don't need that we
don't this like and I was floored at how
well we pulled that off cuz I was like
we're tired and like we really shouldn't
remember like yeah and then you jump to
this and then you do that but because we
were allowed to like improv it was and I
think we had been in it for so long by
that point that we were like yeah yeah
okay a goes to B and then C yeah got it
I'll see you
[Music]
yeah I should be
dead we didn't train we we train side by
side sometimes we well we didn't have
the same train like you would be doing I
I I I tend to work out really in the
morning and it would come a little bit
later but we I mean we had choreography
obviously we had to do together we would
rehearse that I like calling it
rehearsal that's probably not what it is
but it's felt like a dance know it is a
dance I feel like M my character she
especially in episode 8 it's like it's
dirty like it's like like a cat like I
feel like that's Jane very vicious and
can let her emotions when she's
incredibly angry that takes over her
fighting style mhm and I feel like you
might be more measured but I I really
know yeah I feel like yeah it's like you
know I I tried to fight I tried to make
it like technically good but also um
kind of like I I I like it when it looks
like a struggle like I feel like
especially like in the last couple
episodes it's like we would fight and
then but I was like I want to show how
quickly you get tired like I think
people forget how quickly you like you
have a bunch of energies for those first
things but after a few things like you
both like you watch Boxing it's like
yeah they're always people like why are
they laying on each other it's like well
it's very hard you know what they're
doing is very hard so I I tried to like
work that in so it like measured but
then by the like in a couple minutes
you're like trying really hard to you
know keep I feel like in this show a lot
of the missions and I think it's
designed this way are to to provoke or
or sort of poke holes at our own
insecurity so something that you
know John might be doing in a mission
which could be like calling someone it
might unleash this insecurity that Jane
has that why are you on your phone so
much who are you talking to um which is
what Donald and Fran like to call the
Spy sandwich when the with the Spy Trope
can be married into the
relationship um no yeah I think like
Fran
was she always had a really good uh
a really good hold on like the idea
of each episode is a
relationship goal like the boundary like
a kind of like a tent pole of the
relationship and they like kind of named
that way too so she was really good
about like yeah it's influencing us as a
spy but it's really also a relationship
like uh you know buoy and I think like
that really always like for me that was
like kind of a a North star in each
episode where it's like what am I
learning in this episode as far as like
it's like okay like yeah we have to
share space in this episode we're on our
vacation this the first time we're ever
really been in a room like so this is
what I'm I'm learning this as like a
relationship but also as a
spy I'm
scared I mean they all really do help
further I think John and Jane's
character development but I feel like
Parker posie and Parker
and wner but also like Michaela Michaela
for sure I feel like Michaela's like
character was a good turning point for
it was a turning point for our
relationship but so were the
C so haven't seen it she's amazing but
it was um yeah I guess she was a turning
point for our characters and that um it
was the first time you get to see I
think it's the first time you get to see
Jane really reveal her deep feelings for
John and her fears about him and where
they stand in a in a couple and the
first sign of breaking um or going
outside of your relationship what that
means um an establishing trust and then
I I think with with Parker and Wagner it
was like the first time you see uh John
and Jane really um be aligned together
in a way that I feel like a lot of
couples can relate to and I feel like it
was written so well but a of us making
fun of the other couple at the end of a
a dinner
party it's just a job it is not life and
[Applause]
[Music]
death you feel better we had done that
it's funny like that episode got done
last one of the last episodes so we had
done a bunch of stuff already mhm and it
was a it was interesting rehashing that
that stuff well I didn't I I felt like
it it was starting to feel like the
therapist was favoring John and that was
making me really uncomfortable and I I
it it brought out all these feelings
that I felt like Jane was going through
of feeling like this isn't fair she's
just likes you more um and was missing
the point of the therapy but fun yeah
the fun setup cuz it's like yeah it just
feels real like I feel like that's
what's cool about it it's like it's just
so you it's it's far it's like the the
further the farther you run away from
yourself there you are like you can't
get es Escape it it's like we should
we're going here to get help and it's
like but the same problems there so was
[Music]
great